let's start okay we should meditate
meditate welcome to by popular demand
Steve lead
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right well there it is so here we
are
thank you everybody this is a mr. Steve
Lee thanks for coming out brother
boom I just what can I start off however
you want Steve man thank you so much for
just you being there for me mm-hmm
you know I went through a couple hard
times in you and and Craig were there
for me yeah so I really appreciate that
I want to keep it positive I'm not gonna
bring up no dirt I just saying that you
don't want to bring up dirt yeah is
bringing up we're good
no but what you don't understand is like
everybody single day don't lie every
single day without fail if I'm streaming
or it just if anytime I'm on you know
whatever the chats or whatever it's
always when is Steve and Bobbie coming
on to do the movie thing like this is
like like like I'm just like it's so
it's so freakin annoying dude hold up
yeah you already know that I'm in I know
I'm waiting on the two goliaths to come
to the mouth oh wait that's not true
when Bobbie can both were supposed to
come but you were like busy with your
like unboxing or whatever the [ __ ] you
were doing that day on your thing in my
defense TV will not show us so you know
it's so huge right there was not barely
any scheduled time I was in my bathroom
doing content for a vlog you were doing
content okay yeah I was doing a vlog I'm
doing what you're doing man no no I'm
doing what you're doing you've been
doing this longer than I have no no no
in the
no no no you're doing very well
oh my god you're doing very well so if
you haven't subscribed yet we've already
taught you to my subscribers on your
podcast no we're good because I love you
I look at you as a brother I feel the
same way I wish you were you were the it
was like brother Bobby is it you know
those four that talk Bobby anytime I had
like private moments with Bobby he
always says to me like one of the
reasons why him and I are as close as we
are is because of how I am with you he
says that to me all the time
I ask me like you know you do way you
are with my brother you've been there
for my brother and I appreciate that I
look at you later the eldest brother so
I wish it was me Bob and then you were
like that because he's already a middle
child
no no because the the the the the peak
of art the fundus was when me you and
Bob played prisoner of elders yeah those
were the good old days six o'clock in
the morning you know what I mean and you
know I hear they're bringing destiny
they're gonna bring destiny one in to
bring it back and they're gonna they're
gonna incorporate it into the destiny to
like they're not gonna make a destiny
three they're just gonna call a destiny
world yeah and then they're gonna just
have DLCs for like extra content but if
you don't buy that stuff you could still
play yeah yeah even know what you're
talking about right well we're talking
about the debt they don't care okay
there's my viewers are you actually your
viewers I'm just proud of you cuz I'm
looking at your setup and I'm like dude
this guy oh dude I was feeling I wanted
to have you one when he was shitty
because it looked like
inside of your room oh don't start with
that's what people say everybody was
like is that to other side of Steve's
room yeah you know what kind of night I
laughed at it every time you came did my
podcast but when you always referred to
my room as a dorm and the way you talk
about my girlfriend you reveal a [ __ ]
that stuff we only did in the chat yeah
we never talked about that on your
podcast going back I want to have you on
because what do you want to talk about
well here's the thing it's like it's
usually bobbi and you know when Bobby's
here he freaking is like you know he's
like the prom queen you know what I mean
like she just takes over you don't even
like you but you never get any you never
get any love so this time is all about
you you know what I mean did you just
fart no but that was what are you
talking about
it smells like cool no it isn't you
farted no Craig far this is about we
should talk about movies and stuff to
there you've seen or segue into the top
movies I'm looking forward to seeing in
the summer being what are you looking
forward to okay so the number one that
comes to mind is midsummer what's my dad
the director of hereditary re
whatever his scary movie yeah it's about
a Swedish festival in Sweden that
happens every 90 years uh-huh it looks
like some like Blair Witch like some is
rockin do stop is it like lost footage
no no no it's it's it's it seems like
like a cult
Swedish witchcraft type oh wow dude
yeah so that's drop in July third so you
looking for
yes and then the second movie I'm
looking forward to is it chapter two I
just I wasn't into the first one it was
- it was - stranger things II you know I
mean just about like it's like the scary
Goonies you know I mean like here's
something here's like you know it's like
here's like weedy white kids running
around
ya know their bikes I didn't see that
one no he's the clown scary to me
I wasn't that scary what did you like
the original the ones I see the original
and I probably should see the original
before I talk come on yeah I didn't see
the original and then the next movie is
that what is that gamo del Toro's so
he's always good scary movies to see in
the dark something like that right Craig
something like that yeah so that's the
third by the way what do you think about
my new chairs do you like is it
comfortable yeah I like you know what I
like the whole setup it's like very
impressive like that your zoom interface
you have your freaking don't reveal all
my secrets I mean just you know the
thing that makes me most the most
happiest is your camera you know you
know it's dude it looks crisp man well
you know how I got I want to get a
couple more like do like a three camera
but it's so little
yeah yeah oh my god like that you know I
got two chairs no super chat yeah and
when I would I play a Griffin gaming
alright things that people send me like
tips if you tell them I said I'm gonna
buy chairs and use of the chairs I got
because of you guys thank you this I
want to get real we're always real Steve
um it is it hard for you to run your
whole chance cuz you're doing everything
yeah I actually do everything because
Craig's helping me yeah I know you got
Craig oh yeah but you're doing
everything yeah so how much time cuz cuz
you're a busy man uh-huh you've been on
movies television murder mystery on
Netflix okay so check out murder mystery
on Netflix streaming supporting my
brother
um you're on the road doing comedy shows
how do you get how do you where do you
find the time to do all this well you
know I always wonder that because I see
you like doing it too man no no we've
been like yo Steve come hang out with us
and you're like but I have to add it
this is audio I got it and you got your
little headphones and you can use laptop
and you're like that's what I do like a
staff Bobby's got like a grip guy he's
got like a market okay so this is a
better question do you think since we're
doing the podcast game right do you
think it's beneficial to learn all
aspects of your thing you know what I
don't know about you but have you like I
look at a lot of YouTube videos to do
what about this oh you know really dude
I looked at like I look up like so I
have a g85 Panasonic camera Lumix G e85
and so I just looked at I got the g7 so
I just looked yeah so I looked at this
one was on sale that's why I got it oh
we got ours for like how much you pay
I got a rebate from Samy's camera he
would have it it was it was no tax for
the instant rebate yeah Wow look at that
lens I know it's great and I actually
bought another lens but I actually want
to send it back because it just it's not
as good yeah I guess if I just want to
take pictures so I go online and I look
up I could look up g85 best YouTube
settings and then like there's all these
videos of these nerds and they're just
like hey guys thanks for watching and
here's yeah and I just sit through it I
had my camera in my hand and I just
follow exactly what they say
no problem I have it now I'm trying to
deal with is duh is the sound so like
same kind of thing you look up like a CH
Cyg Zune logic you know logic X yeah you
look up like what's the proper settings
that's a little harder cuz I'm not a
sound engineer right these [ __ ]
complain all the time they're in the tea
no they're in the chat
you're the trolls are just like man you
soon people like it half the people
don't so yeah I'm still working it out
but look I just like to progress look I
got chairs yeah I'm gonna work on the
sound I got I'm trying to get great gas
it's just it just is what it is so I I
saw that and you were talking about how
you you've been in you know the business
13 years television yeah but then you
notice that like lately people recognize
you more from this not necessarily more
but they're more engaged I think I think
it's just direct-to-consumer man that's
like you know that people are out there
and they're just like oh they they feel
like a personal connection cuz we're
talking like this this is more personal
than anything that would be on TV like
The Tonight Show or something like that
yeah just on the couch doing like a bit
as opposed to like we're sitting here
we're clearly close we clearly have a
rapport and then dude when is the first
time we you don't want to like at least
it might be no I don't know if it's that
long because it could be the first time
I know news that the comedies no no no
no oh I remember
dude can I can I bring up a story no no
but the first time I have a comedy story
all right cool but the first time I met
you was at the Comedy Store just briefly
Steve Bobby's like this is my brother
but the first time we actually really
hung out is when I whooped you at FIFA
at Bobby's place you were so upset yeah
beat you now we got to stream it we will
be streaming FIFA look out for that I
remember walking up to you I was at the
store and then I think cuz you're cuz
you're probably used to like you're sick
of people like random fans coming up to
you and the hallway am I sick of it
truce I remember one time I walked up to
you and I go it was like you we weren't
really fully acquainted I don't know I
went up dude I go what's up man
and then you looked at me like Steve
you're like what what's up yeah because
I go what's up man give you a little bit
of a weirdo I'm pretty weird yeah you're
[ __ ] weirdo you can't just walk up to
people and be like you know I am weird
yeah no no I am a weird I do weird
things yeah you're the weird side I am
you creeping me out I am weird yeah I I
do weird things you do yeah thanks by
the way that's an art by the way that's
great yeah you know what I'm happy for
you man I don't we're trying to do it
this is a thing this is is this
fulfilling to you like doing the YouTube
like I mean like what makes you happy
um I got win in the lottery and just
retiring to an island I think that would
be I'm talking about content creation
being a content creator um I don't know
I mean I just think that like being able
to sit down with people that you like
maybe you don't know people and then you
get to know them or people that you know
like you
yeah you just can sit down and shoot the
[ __ ] it's kind of fun like I really wish
we were doing like what's gonna in a
patent it's just gonna be me and you do
in the movies you know cuz it's just
hard to get that [ __ ] locked
down we should we are gonna talk no no
no I want let's keep it a hundred
uh-huh are we gonna do it are we gonna
do dude I have no idea what are we
waiting for word for us to go to the
singing mic so cuz Bob's busy yeah he's
busy with I mean to have the podcaster
shall not be we don't say the T word
here on this podcast we don't do do we
or don't we I'm only kidding I love
Tiger Bailey and I love all the tiger
bellyfit make sure you just subscribe to
tiger belly they already are oh they are
yeah yeah I would say most of my fans
were tiger by the fans that's why there
are we
doing that other successful podcast we
should figure out what do we notice
because I'm like III study your stuff as
well I'm like okay okay Eric's got the
bricks samurai sword Eric's got this
what aren't we doing to make more
content we're making a lot of code no no
no this is okay this this what we're
doing Stevie we do this can be nervous
with my wand
no but check it out check it out we
because I'm I'm trying to learn as we go
you know I want to learn with you you
know we're I'm learning with you already
doing that no no no we are building on
your stuff we know you got on my nerves
before I even started doing this school
Craig Craig was like what I was telling
him about this you know how meticulous
he is I was like okay I gotta get like
wall make sure there's no shadows has
helped of course like so do this guy I
got the light you don't have to defend
it but I want to say something don't
sleep on air Fross oh here we go
[Laughter]
tell us tell us why cuz what people the
mistakes people make with especially
with our buddy here I don't I don't want
to name any names but I just want to
keep it within me the bubble of the
Internet so everyone Craig Craig Craig
knows his stuff that's okey I'll leave
it that he does know his stuff but he's
just annoying about knowing his stuff
that's the thing yeah you know lights
Griffin I don't want to see me so I was
like [ __ ] you brick but was he right and
I got the [ __ ] whites look I got like
butts Terry my point he was right I
gotta how great these lows are okay
though Kevin I got the lights I got the
camera
shoutout to Craig for the house okay so
can i we're trying to figure it out look
at Steve yeah you I love this when I
originally jealous no wait we have a
little joke
no but my original setup light I love
this my original [ __ ] table I had a
lot of nonsense on it that was inspired
by you I was like I got it I said I
gotta get as much clutter as possible
you're like I was inspired by your okay
hey listen this is the thing I admit it
I don't know what I'm doing that's the
fun part
yeah but how do we cuz I look at other
YouTube channels right like this how
they are like hey how you doing today my
name is today we're gonna learn how to
make these blueberry french toast
anyways you know they're like all like
engaging that's not you your [ __ ] is
over you should have to come out the
thing like a serial killer
and then like you have your own thing
Steve I love you no but this is the
thing people love you don't you know but
this is the thing you have to in order
to to be successful in this youtube
podcasting game you have to do your
research and see okay what is successful
out there in this in this social media
content creating platform no you know
what our problem is we're close to
somebody that is like so successful that
we're always comparing ourselves to that
that's the problem
who are you talking wait you know it's
like you're your brother like Tiger
belly is so big like everything we do
were like oh we're not quite Tiger belly
yeah we got to stop that because you are
all trying to figure no I don't want to
compare and despair with that because
that's family compare and despair um
what what are they doing that we aren't
doing cuz you're getting the cat I mean
you're getting big names the names
you're getting I can't get those people
yes you can
no right I could get but the names like
it
again I can't get someone with a Yeti I
don't know I don't hang out at skate
parks in like you know I would go to the
B rapper studios and wait in the back
[Laughter]
but you've had porn stars you've got
like real you know we're trying to
expand you know I'm trying to get like
better I there's only so much I could do
that's what me and Craig we're talking
about
there's only like even with you there's
only so I know there's you know you have
so many why but that's why I don't know
how to reach their PR or their managers
but that's my males how do I do that but
what we do has to be enough like you
just being Steve as why people watch
okay you just need to understand that
people watch because of you it doesn't
know whoever sitting in the seat it
doesn't matter cuz it's just how you
interact with people that people love
okay so can I do can I can i play this
can I do this trivia game with you as
far as your top three top five if you
could in in in an ideal world for
riffing with Griffin who would be an
ideal five dream guest Oh God dr. Dre I
would love to have dr. Dre sit there dr.
Dre what's your view this good one at a
time I do but what about you Tom Hanks
Tom oh yeah that's a good that be a good
Dead or Alive or they have to be have to
be doable
I don't know no they'd have to be alive
okay okay okay you said dr. Dre I said
Tom Hanks okay okay you go again you're
number two Seinfeld I'd love to have
Seinfeld Jerry Seinfeld on phone
MF DOOM who's that this is what I'm
saying you can get that guy my favorite
rapper producer this is what I'm saying
I know just go down to down oh I'm not
judging your list
so let's but I thought this was a list
of people that we possibly know that is
the dream guest that's your dream guest
yeah producer no one's heard of I take
offense to that I'm gonna let you keep
doing this okay three on you this is fun
right yeah so that we all have both have
to watch the creators of Game of Thrones
just like a Kirstie's [ __ ] game
of Thrones yeah Quentin Tarantino
Tarantino yeah I don't want to talk to
him okay so number four um who would I
want to talk to um you know what I want
to talk to this is a weird one but
Steven Naismith he's he's on he's on
ESPN he's a sports talk guy I mean the
sports team sorry you're into weird rap
about this yeah okay Daniel day-lewis
Michael Jordan I don't want to talk to
Michael Jordan Jordan yeah okay uh just
give me a second give me a second give
me a second um give me a second
[Music]
Frank black from The Pixies
oh Jesus Christ didn't your sportscaster
card but you two weirdos on your listed
that this is a historical moment ladies
and gentlemen first time ever this is
crazy
you know how come Asian legs that like
the bottle no a bottle bit are you doing
a bit Asian my legs I could now okay
going why is it Chewbacca on the bottom
and like a young gay boy at the top like
a game of Thrones review or something we
in the great area about that things I
did not like about let's hear it
I did not like how the the night king
got taken out oh just too fast I mean
dude it's like it's kind of like that's
how Darth Vader's going out like right I
wanted to see you epic lights it you
know I'm saying Jon Snow versus you know
saying I agree even if it was Arya you
don't have been sick instead you had
like a ninja branch move and then she
like went like this and did some kind of
like boom like some weird ninja move
that's it
so that threat is gone within five
seconds yeah it was cool threat of
whitewash for seven years
hold on within like one move boom boom
they're all dead
um I didn't like how Daenerys went out
yes you were too crazy oh no before even
that I don't like how Jaime Lannister
and Cersei went out yeah they should
have died dude that was so like
uneventful say you're gonna die
underground like he's gonna leave
he had like a fight where he was gonna
die anyway because he was gonna bleed
out cuz that fight he had with what the
other guy but like her she's not
supposed to just walk down the stairs
yes it that was weird
okay cuz I don't want to just go
negative
I like the the fight versus the Hound
versus the man that was great and I
predicted that yeah what I thought was
gonna happen at the end I thought Arya
was gonna bum-rush you know Cersei
uh-huh and I thought it was gonna be
like a duel kind of battle like Arya
versus Cersei what that murder her
though I know that would be sick I don't
want her to die like hugging Jaime you
know what I did not like right okay so
Rianna Taurus is that her name yeah Anna
Taurus so Brianna Taurus Jaime Lannister
right they got their hooking up it was
romantic
I mean it could have got married that
day alright so you're telling me they
went they did all that and then the next
morning Jaime just decides to wake up
and say argh I gotta go yeah he just you
know come on he had to hid he loved his
sister yeah sister more than anything
what I didn't like is like why is she
writing in the [ __ ] book about him
who like why is she write nice things
about him yeah if you could he if he had
to choose between them he would kill her
for his sister yeah he's in the book
writing about nice things about him I
don't not him like that either
oh the whole thing with brand and just
how they like he was nominated and the
guy who was gone for like three seasons
I always say that I always say that I
think they like in the writers room they
had like pictures on the wall of all the
actors and then somebody closed their
eyes and threw a dart
he opened his eyes he was like okay
brands the night king he's gonna be the
you know everybody everybody start
writing you know do you think that they
kind of rushed through this last season
it felt like it to me come on
didn't it feel like it and that one
episode it was so great
like yeah like what is going on here the
dragons going into like smoke so bad bad
bad feeling weird okay so that was my
review on to the so what else can we
talk about whatever you want man movie
that you even saw Oh Coco Coco okay the
Pixar movie okay tell us about Coco ste
Coco review first of all it wasn't one
of the it was one of the best Steve
what's our move on in the theater no no
I want to talk about coke okay go ahead
beautiful story really what was the
story about about this this little
Mexican kid who who comes from their fam
family lineage um like musics in their
lineage but like they're his
great-great-great grandfather right like
like left um the woman to pursue his
music and so he was like shunned from
the family and so the whole movie is
like this kid wanting to figuring out
how he just wants to follow that lineage
but it dude it's beautifully it's
beautifully written there's like um it's
like what's the day of the dead called
the the morte day that something day of
the dead the more tape right like
there's an astral plane within the world
right where he has to go cross over to
like that world and navigate through
that world and it's a dude
I hadn't even I cried there's a scene
and you're still clean right
I don't like that you're really Coco
Coco
received Craig to move you just so you
saw it on Netflix yeah that's nice
shout out to your girlfriend right but I
know you will look at you and I know
what you're about that don't we go to
her we go to her sister's house for
boxing parties right isn't that her or
was that kalila you act like it's my
true you act like I'm deciding there
we're not all hanging out I have you
know I have not seen it yet it took us
forever to pick I mean just be happy for
I am happy it's it's nice it's good
that's good Oh so let's go back to what
you saw what's the last many more
because we don't want you to talk about
Coco I want to talk about how we're all
gonna make this movie channel work I
think this would be okay I think there
should be a meeting off air I don't know
well I think one we're gonna pick better
movies to talk Coco yeah better day well
if we were talking about cartoons okay
so top is Coco your number one cartoon
of all time that's how about that this
is make your top ten Coco when you're
it's it's up there yeah okay so it's
better than Aladdin yeah no way dude are
you guys why are you doing is Coco
better give your wizard Oh Aladdin
Aladdin is it I want it original Aladdin
yes okay okay I love rest in peace I
love Coco is on par with Aladdin okay I
just came in to be okay I know I just
toys story one two I have another trivia
game that's gonna be fun right now
what's your top ten top five
Robin Robin Williams movie go okay
number one is it's always gonna be
Jumanji okay
Jumanji is always gonna be number one
for me okay number two is gonna be a
listing one where he was like it's not
your fault
it's not your fault good Good Will
Hunting he gave one to Oscar for Good
Will Hunting number I don't even know
after that Oh what will be Aladdin okay
Aladdin it'll be a laugh okay yeah but
can I'm gonna add to this as well um
what's another good Robin Williams movie
I can't even think of another good oh
you love all creepy [ __ ] you're just a
creepy [ __ ] guy I like good movies it's
called method acting okay
okay now I'm gonna add okay no no okay
give me a chance go number one okay
mrs. Doubtfire oh my god Steve you're
killing me when I wanted I remember mrs.
Doubtfire no no no it's my turn
um yeah 24-hour photo no that that's not
even on the list it's my list you get
your list this is my how how is nota for
overall area four number four is Good
Will Hunting Good Will Hunting oh you're
dead
Good Will Hunting and then for our photo
is before Good Will Hunting you know I
refuse to say Aladdin I don't want to
use your choice so I'm really doing my
because of your choices I forgot about
that
Oh see Fisher King now that was okay
Fisher King but that's but that's better
than 24 hour phone oh all right what's
your okay you okay are we doing my list
it's still Jumanji is still number one
that's a classic yeah [ __ ] you see
Jumanji mrs. Doubtfire Good Will Hunting
good morning Vietnam and then what was
the other one
Aladdin that's myself I've heard Robin
Williams Craigs over here shaking his
head Craig you're both creeps you both
creeps that was the creepiest movie I
wouldn't have thought oh let me ask you
something what were those trivia games
fun and I just presented to you and that
was not even playing was that fun is
that what you want to do on our show
yeah well I want to add stuff like that
okay I feel you okay top five top five
Will Smith movies go wow that's your
number one Will Smith
moving okay I'm just asking let me tell
you something about that scene that
scene at the end when he gets the
promotion and he's worked so hard
uh-huh to get that promotion and do you
see that acting and you see his eyes
water up and he walks out of that
building and then he walks onto the
street that was a beautiful scene that's
your number one it's up there I mean
that was a great you mentioned it first
cement okay men in black the original
men in black okay that's your number
okay you know my mind went blank because
I'm thinking of like why he's been so
prolific he's been in everything but I
can't remember one thing I know sorry
well you did you do another one how
about this oh we got no we gonna
continue with this you can't just change
in mid bid go we got we cope we both got
men in black yeah they're okay this is
name off movies Hancock was an enemy of
the state
[Music]
remember all huh
Oh Independence Day Oh what's the one I
like that one I like to to but it got
weird in the end it was just him and his
dog I know but in the end the dissolve I
didn't like the zombie effect but the
first half not very good the first
quarter yeah I totally agree
come on yeah totally agree now how fun
would it be I'm just gonna segue into a
video game idea oh here we go
how fun would it be to play a video game
where you're like the only dude left on
earth mm-hmm and you have to solve it
like there's a workbench and you have to
like craft like different survival tools
and stuff oh you mean that shitty game
that's already out there what's the call
when the Bobby always likes to play by
himself the moments a [ __ ] graphics it
just came out and it just bombed and
helped us out part 2 what's the game -
Bobby likes to play all the time no it's
that one game where you craft weapons
and you're you you you have that you
guys played it all the time fallout
fallout yes it's all that's terrible
what is your problem Steve the last
fallout bomb here so horribly that the
company was gonna go out of business no
that last game but fallout 3 and news
Vegas were masterpieces no they were
masterpiece masterpieces you don't agree
oh my god you're so wrong I tried to
play you're wrong
the graphic now I just wanna let you
know no you're wrong is that your
favorite game of all time it's one of
the best games ever made okay top five
games of all time go you want to do this
yeah yeah
Shadow of the Colossus that's your
number one listen there's only one game
that could be your number one shadow off
the clock no [ __ ] way shadow did you
did you play Shadow the Colossus for
five years now you have to turn on the
mic
are you happy with that happy no did you
play that game for five years I loved it
did you play it for five years right
like eight big okay Liza what game have
you played consistently for five years
fallout 3 no no you know
Destiny's the only game you've played
consistently for five years okay that's
it that's your fate that's the best
that's the best game that's gotta no one
can you no other game you've played you
know what you're right you're right I've
had I've had there's pros and cons about
it of course but you know what destiny
is a damn fun game I still have fun
playing with you guys yeah I don't know
what it is me number it's still kind of
fun to be number two would be FIFA and
I'm just counting them all there's
different thing about FIFA what I just
lately the last three years what
well that's one's good to barbae have
you said 19 no no but this is what I
like about all of them now go cuz
managerial mode Alice I'd never do that
dude it's the funnest thing ever
well that's why it's like baseball cards
you could really I'm researching on my
phone like I'm like okay like real
players and I'm like okay what's their
growth potential well that's why I have
time to work on my podcast cuz I'm not
doing that at Oriel mode everything you
say towards me is like a no but FIFA
yeah I I don't like doing that because I
something about I haven't got into that
mode it's not a bad moment you would
love it dude you love sports but you
don't have you ever done that mode where
you make your own character I play I
love that yeah I I just started that
like two years ago I did it with some
people I met online and what I realized
about that was like oh that's actually
pretty fun like you know and you have to
build up your courage but what I found
is like that's a completely different
game than playing Fifa like season mode
and pleasured I agree that's why I like
it
it's like a chain it's like a change in
pace but yeah I would say FIFA's number
two for me
and then like I don't really those are
really the only two games that I
consistently I can't even look dude I
gotta say gold and I was probably number
three for me okay since you're going way
back okay cuz cuz I was gonna bring it
back too so for the PlayStation 2 like
the og one of the og Wow I used to play
a game this is before the UFC games
right but bit do you remember you
remember pride fighting no I never cried
wasn't a fighting organization in Japan
right like that's where the grace he's
fought that's where like like Kazushi
Sakuraba got discovered that's where
like freaking Igor Vovchanchyn
dawn fry fry fought there but there was
a video game that they put out where you
kid like it was awesome played dude I
must have played I don't know how many
hours I spent planning but dude it was
really really really fun I used to be
fighting back in the day I used to be
into NBA Live those were fun - yeah back
but like if I had to go back to the my
more favorite ones would be like when
NBA Live was on like the Janis not the
Genesis and the Nintendo one in the
Tendo 64 cube another Nintendo 64 like
back then when my MBA life first came
out helped us out you know those were
the those I liked those games like Sonic
the Hedgehog that was like one of my
favorites that was fun yes sonic Mario
and Mario Brothers you know oh your tie
you're bringing back to Nintendo I'm
just saying my top five games that I
like I just figure like I played
consistently and really enjoyed playing
you know I just think for me Destiny's
always gonna be number one because I
can't get away from that stupid game you
know what I don't know cuz okay when we
played last night let's bring it to
label it's like recent history yeah okay
dude okay I'm gonna ask you some general
questions I felt like when we're playing
crucible iron banner I felt like when
we're playing and I
got killed by someone on their team
right I feel like my guns I was using
guns from like 1992 like are my guns
like like the meta
okay so there's referring to the meta
yeah because I played in a while I know
but what it like I don't like the fact
that like like a gun that was really
decent like a year ago like mitem the
might a multi-tier but you talk about a
gun that was like been in the game for
like 10 years you're right it's like why
would that game still be good you're
right so are there guns where they just
never go out of style no why do you what
are you using the CI what's your primary
weapon but I don't have like I like that
one the madman man maleficents or
magnificent sörman if whatever
yeah it's that one that taken gun yeah
you don't use it for gambit it's not
necessarily for game no no no no no no
but if for gambit that's forgiven when a
person from their team comes over and it
is for gambit you could kill them easier
yeah I like that gun yeah you know what
I'm saying is like why do I still play
that game is I don't know it's so no no
this is what it is and I've thought
about this endless nights they have like
the the Vegas gambling yeah like when
you arrive yeah when you do when you
have your engrams and well you know it's
like when the purple cuz you know purple
because we're like kind of like
brainwash when the purple Prime and
Graham drops it's like going to Vegas on
the slot machines where you see that
purple thing but it's being devalued
dopamine's released it's been devalued
don't you think it's not as valuable
like you get it and then you go get
there no no no but I thought okay but
then I have another argument they don't
just do that you know how like there's
so many tasks they have to do like you
even said like oh my god the calibration
for the auto rifle you get that then you
get mod components I know and so it's
like what destiny they always keep you
busy it's like a to-do list it's like
you have 20 to-do lists and you're like
it you know I'm not like how it was
though it used to be that we when we
would play with Bobby we would be like
okay we have to go do this like we need
to go do like like you would go Duke
Road
after a reset yeah cuz you got that
because you've got no grasp omalley it
doesn't matter I'm just saying you would
get a good ass weapon you know yeah good
what's the incentive now like it's going
suck okay you brought up a good point
we're playing gambit last night with the
boys and then today when we when we mean
Craig I hear you're like yeah I go
you're like yeah I like yeah but but
like there's no rewards yes so why are
we playing rats my point but why am i
playing it like when you finish it like
how about this you didn't even do though
what does that [ __ ] call Craig when you
go to uh you go to that new planet and
you have to go do that you know you have
to go turn that thing on and you have to
go to the different bubbles and like all
that [ __ ] I forgot what that's called
but anyway it's not the forge but even
the forge you haven't done the forge yet
spider is no you have to do this thing
you have to do this like activity where
it takes a good twenty five minutes okay
and when you're done with it you don't
have a prize it made it worth it and
that's why I don't like playing those
things well why why well but why do you
do it that's what I'm saying that's why
I don't do it it no no no I know why I
know why we do it because at least this
is the visit of my only reasoning this
is my only logical explanation it's
because when you do those Green bounties
for specifically for gambit you get a
powerful weapon no but you don't back me
up on this one trying to tell you don't
do you get a power no you don't you get
a priming no you don't let's get
something you don't get a powerful
weapon exactly why are we playing it
because both we're playing it because
we've been playing it for five years but
back in the day when you completed an
activity like that you got a weapon that
should be higher than any weapon you
already have that's the problem that
we're now is that you get these weapons
where you go
I can't even infuse it it's useless so
why are we doing it and not only that
it's like eager talk but okay okay but
member and destiny one like you didn't
have to like jump through through hoops
to infuse a weapon no no you needed it
up mask or 80,000 glimmer it
like you need [ __ ] 90,000 mod
component materials it's just not that
makes it not fun
why do I I mean Craig hates it too here
do that that's one I know why can't why
we play them Oh cuz we like play with
each other that's why yeah it's a
communal game that's why okay now let me
out
do you miss trials of Osiris I miss all
that stuff no I don't even like you went
to the lighthouse didn't you only cuz
that one kid carried me cuz I cuz we
never went yeah you did you guys never
went yeah but dude there's parts of that
game we've never done and we never will
do there's three this is the thing I I
didn't I didn't play destiny for like
three or four
I haven't played games in a while I know
[Music]
this is what I realize about gaming and
I don't want to like sound like a broken
right the reai love talking to you guys
but sometimes i just want to be isolated
yeah I get you you know how Bob likes
doing his on your brain off you just
like it's like a mindless activity I
just want to get lost my world it could
be worse and apparently as some gaming
is good for your like brain activity
like what Justin II don't know I'm just
saying that gaming at to be good for
your hand-eye coordination
keep sure like brain active so you know
but anyways let's not turn into a gaming
we already have one called worst
fireteam wfv everybody out there all you
gamers subscribe to worst fireteam
WFP well at least a singer mike is
getting some use you're the only guest
that you can you can we can we make it a
point where I could come I could I come
on here whenever I want Steve
open invitation but come on on the
contrary will you come on mine to do a
part every time we should do a part one
part two that's I will do well every
time you come on mine uh-huh
people just love it cuz you roast me the
whole time okay in my defense and this
is what's [ __ ] right now
Steve meets me at the door goes remember
to roast me okay
you tell me like I like I didn't you
come and [ __ ] get mad at me I love it
I do it for an hour strange there's
enough material yeah you see you have
the hot plate is the hot plate still
there and here's a piano that like first
of all there's no room for piano in his
in his in his [ __ ] dorm room and he
has a piano you know I mean I'm
surprised you didn't upgrade to a grand
piano that'll be hilarious if you had a
grand piano we got to get a green screen
set up there for you okay so let's go
back to content creating upgrades yes
because this will help all the players
you know whoa wait wait wait wait wait
wait hold it no no hold it no this is I
like what you're saying right yeah so
what are we gonna do right now is we're
gonna put it out to the fans right now
how can Steve and I improve our podcast
for you guys what do you want to see so
he can get more things make sure you put
that in the comments email me and
something Steve's gonna come back and
we're gonna try to work on those I just
say well what do you think I'd go back
when you anyway just just to add onto
that go go go but I already know what
rolls gonna say well you could first
start at not cutting your guests off
Jesus Christ yes now I know who the
troll is this is we're having a
conversation okay so ask me again ask me
the same question ask me the question
again [ __ ] you because I literally
blanked out exactly you mean when you
cut me off to make that ridiculous point
yeah I'm just in the middle of a
conversation and we're talking
these [ __ ] he's [ __ ] trolls
man they act like I'm not supposed to
talk on my own [ __ ] podcast I'm so so
you know I won't do that it's fine Steve
you're fine okay so it's your question
what are we gonna do to improve our
podcast this is this is a your podcast
my podcast in our joint podcast what are
we gonna do well this is a thing I can't
solve the question with the quit with
the brain that came up with a question
if that makes any sense
I don't know what the [ __ ] did he just
say like please can we can we get that
figured out some theories okay go ahead
I think that I need to do content that
is unique that is not really readily
available out there yet whether it's
like what well I just come with me like
I I take public transportation right me
like cuz every time I ride the train I
see something crazy [ __ ] go down which
is crazy that you live in LA which is
insane
so I was I always think man if I had a
GoPro this would have bit this it would
be a worldstar hit like I've gotten like
I've seen crazy stuff like that go down
on a train you know what you're just
we're like a grand no but that's all
like on a necklace
I'll give you an idea you say well what
kind of vlogger and that's that'd be my
ID okay so it's like Steve on public
transportation yeah like on the red okay
yeah and then red lines so red live walk
hold up ste B's red line vlogs yeah or
Stevie red zones on the red line
okay so you want it okay so you want to
see more man on the street type stuff
yeah man on the street type stuff okay
what about you um actually I think uh I
think maybe I should like use the
singing mic more like actually make a
song you know I mean like with the
guests wait I'm just gonna cut you off
right there why don't you just rolls he
cuts you off music let me tell you
something
you could obviously sing pretty damn
good cuz I've been to karaoke with you
you can definitely hold a note huh
you can literally that's another thing
like this that you like the truth DVD
you could would you definitely cop that
but with this you can have your own
album dude we'll see so that's just my
as long as you have a guest appearance
on my album I would loved how about this
I would love that we should do that
we're gonna make it smart how about this
that's what we're gonna go how about
this Steve and I are gonna gather you me
and Bob we make a holiday oh here we go
Bob
Bob like we can get him alright just
maybe we can't even alright just me and
you me and you we make the holiday a
Christmas out Halloween album yeah
because we like scary movies yeah
Halloween oh okay then we make a
Christmas album yeah follow up and then
we have a box set called holidays we
make music videos so can I just do a
commercial a quick commercial for you
know where can where can your reviewers
purchase your DVD well they don't nobody
first of all nobody buys DVDs anymore so
but what I just have so many of them
where could they watch your special you
can it's off you have Showtime you can
see it's streaming if you'd like a copy
of signed copy go to Eric Griffin comm
Erik Griffin comm make sure you watch
his comedy special the ugly truth thank
you
thank you Steve no I mean I had your
album right here plug whatever you want
to plug cuz okay Lee ladies and
gentlemen do you need uh Stevie Wiebe
has his own website go to
[Music]
did you have fun yes okay I love you man
I love you so much
we're know I do I love you I love you
seriously like I would tell you I would
jump if I'll take a bullet for you you
know I would take a bullet Bobby you
know I know it
Bobby and I talked about this and you
know it I said the same thing about you
two I would take a bullet for you I was
not tested died for you that's how much
love I have for Eric Griffin well I
appreciate did we at least make an hour
yeah I think so I think we had an hour
okay so we'll see if I ask you back
you'll know it well but what could I do
Steve there's nothing more you can do no
I want to promote like this episode for
you and me as well we're gonna do it
we're gonna you're gonna have the social
media stuff you know we're gonna we're
gonna tweet it out we're gonna like have
look you know we're gonna do everything
we can do can you do this I'm not asking
for the world but can you in the in the
description bar yeah can you link my
youtube channel I did it last time what
even when you and your brother I have
all the links they're like you know yeah
I did it by the way on my episode when I
was on your episode I don't I didn't see
any links I don't know whose we're not
going to talk about nobody's plug away
okay so
go to my Instagram qu a NGO you I also
have a YouTube channel itself you
ww-wait youtube.com slash the EP weepy
smash that subscribe button
[Music]
this is the first time I'm worth reading
having a singing that was fun right dude
well sing that much who else did ten top
fives Coco for like ten minutes so I
love you I love you too Steve
anyway that's Steve Lee everybody and
you will see us again we're gonna work
on our podcasts if you have ideas on
like ideas on our movie podcast like
what you should do where should we do it
like ideas concepts like hit us up on
social media hit us up in the comments
hit us up just email me Eric at Eric
Griffin comm again make sure you
subscribe to both our podcast not to
mention we're friend with Griffin and I
really appreciate you guys listening and
watching I love this guy Steve even my
brother and I came on freaking die for
him we're here and we'll continue to be
here we're gonna get to you put pumping
out content because that's what we do
and I appreciate you every day every
week every week we're doing that and
he's got you he also has his unboxing
he's got his like you know he's got his
own podcast and we're gonna be doing a
joint podcast and we're doing this we'll
come back here until we figure this [ __ ]
out and I appreciate you guys watching
and I'll see you next week thank you